as a constitutional
lawyer professor yourself
what what we're seeing happening in
australia versus our constitution how
different is our constitution versus
australia i don't know if this is a
topic you can go into only reason i ask
is how are we citizens of america
protected by the constitution
constitution differently than australia
well
australia um
is in the british tradition the
tradition
is on written constitutions australia
has written documentation but we're
different countries could you take spend
20 seconds just telling me what it is in
australia that you're so uh that you're
so concerned about and then i'll give
you my constitutional analysis about
whether that could happen here have you
have you been following any of the
stories of what's going on in australia
have you seen some of the videos
going on i hear your stories on both
sides so
yeah i mean what what you're seeing uh
being a concern where some common
question being asked by again the
average person in america is you're
seeing videos of if you don't get
vaccinated you can't get out you can't
work you can't get income
to that point of control you're seeing
videos people getting out
there's massive protesting writing going
on some people are fighting this some
don't have a choice obviously there's a
different side to australia there's one
region of australia where it's a little
bit more free there's another region
that's fully controlled and we had a guy
on the podcast from australia called in
saying people are being forced to lose
their jobs they can't make income unless
they get vaccinated can a situation like
that ever happen in america
yes it could let me tell you what could
not happen what could not happen is a
repeat of what happened
in 1943 when a liberal united states
supreme court uh led by hugo black who
claimed to be a libertarian allowed the
detention of 110 000 japanese americans
many of them citizens we know what
happened in cuba during the beginning of
the aids crisis cuba created detention
camps not only for aid sufferers but for
gay
cubans who were thought to be in fear of
catching and communicating aids i don't
think that can happen i wrote a book
some years ago called rights from wrongs
in which i argue that many of our rights
grow out of a recognition of the wrongs
that we inflicted and the japanese
american internment between 43 and 45 is
one of those historic wrongs we'll never
do it again so i don't think we'll ever
be in a situation where people are going
to be locked up uh for not receiving a
vaccine but i think we might very well
be in a situation if the science
mandates it and the court upholds it
where people can not have jobs where
people can't go to work did you see that
right
that right there scares the hell out of
the average person
the average person well it also should
scare the hell out of the average person
to know that you go to work and sitting
next to you is somebody who is
unvaccinated unmasked and unwilling to
say whether he or she is vaccinated or
not so we're going to get scared people
on both sides and the question is
whether or not a government has the
right to say that people who go to work
have the right to work in a safe
environment and not be exposed to
typhoid mary's who might very well
give them an illness to remember too
that although today
omicron doesn't seem to be as serious as
symptomatology as other
forms of the covet we don't know about
long covert we're hearing about all
kinds of possibilities that people
without symptoms may have problems their
heart neurological problems we just
don't know we're going to have to
continue to operate under circumstances
of
imperfect information both on the
vaccine side and on the illness side and
that's the question that's posed in a
democracy who gets to make these tragic
choice decisions which have no good
outcome only bad ones the decisions are
bad worse worser worsest and intolerable
and when you get those kinds of choices
rather than good better or best
democracies often have a very hard time
choosing among choices of evils so we're
in for a tough time the constitution
will be very very severely tested but
yes we could get to a situation in
america where american citizens are told
they can't come to work unless they're
vaccinated so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you